[Music]
Florida's governor declared a state of
emergency to help fight the corona virus
outbreak but it comes amid spring break
for millions of Americans the state pop
the state's popular beaches have been
expecting large crowds but tourism
officials say they are worried about the
potential impact of the outbreak on
businesses Manuel Bojorquez is in Miami
Beach for us many good morning so I
would expect the crowds would be a
little bit smaller this year is that the
case good morning officials certainly
hope the crowds will not be smaller they
say during the spring break season they
can get anywhere from three to five
thousand visitors per day here at iconic
South Beach and with so many people at
one place at one time many beach goers
say they are taking extra precautions to
try to stay healthy
great it's cold back home tourists are
still flocking to Florida for spring
break despite concerns over coronavirus
visitors to South Beach will see newly
installed hand-washing stations directly
on the sand others say they'll carry
their own hand sanitizer on vacation I
always have it on me because it's like
you walk up you touch railings you go to
class you like don't want to touch your
face it's so slick bad a CDC warning
isn't stopping people from boarding
cruise ships either a day after the
agency cautioned against ship travel
seven cruise ships left the Port of
Miami excited passengers waving as they
departed so far Florida's Health
Department has identified at least 15
cases of corona virus to turn deadly
one near Pensacola the other near Fort
Myers four other cases have been found
just north of Miami public gatherings
can pose a risk or officials have
canceled two major events the Ultra
Music Festival and the Calle Ocho
celebration each drawing crowds in the
hundreds of thousands are now called off
Ultra Music Festival ticket buyers were
informed Monday night that they will not
get a refund we
put the welfare and safety of our
residence for any amount of money at
risk but money is a concern for the
hospitality industry more than 23
million people visited Miami in 2018 so
what are we doing it to prevent it a
meeting was held in Miami Beach on
Monday so business leaders could hear
directly from health officials we're
doing everything we can to get through
this and with with the least amount of
damage possible obviously to public
health and secondarily to our economy
does anything about this keep you up at
night all of this keeps me up at night
because there's so much uncertainty dan
Rowe head of Panama City beaches tourism
operation says he's worried too but he
insists the Gulf Coast town is open for
business and safe for everyone
yeah the corona virus is out there you
know but it's no different here than it
is at home yeah so until there's travel
restrictions you know limiting people's
ability to travel around the southeast
come on down to the beach and take those
same precautions you would at home many
families actually drive down to Florida
instead of flying for spring break so
the Department of Transportation has
added educational materials at rest
stops along the interstates as a net
another measure to try to stop the
spread of the virus
Michelle folks do need a break thank you